le conseil municipal de perpignan vient
de prendre une décision qui va sans
doute faire couler beaucoup d'encre et
de salive dans cette ville bien sûr mais
aussi dans tout l'hexagone
l'interdiction de toutes m'ont dit cité
dans le centre ville durant l'été 1993
suite à une réforme du code pénal
la mendicité n'est plus considérée comme
un délit
alors la même année pour lutter contre
ces mendiants certaines mairies décident
de recourir à des arrêtés
perpignan est la première grande ville à
dégainer son règlement anti mendicité
voilà une ville en crise économique et
il lui faut se donner une image nouvelle
perpignan la catalane doit être mise en
scène et c'est dans le centre ville que
se joue cette image le même été 1993
d'autres villes du sud imite perpignan
il y à carcassonne si on a interdit aux
gens demandaient qu'on a mis directement
la rue parle de problèmes sociaux et que
c'est des états qui les ont mis à la rue
qui réparent leur erreur avant de mettre
les interdictions cannes depuis le 1er
octobre
il est interdit de mendier sur la voie
publique et sur les principales artères
de la ville de cannes cette décision a
été prise par son maire michel mouillot
ces arrêtés font polémique au sein des
municipalités
mais à l'été 1995 le débat devient
nationale lorsque la mairie de la
rochelle une ville de gauche prend elle
aussi un arrêté anti mendicité pendant
le festival des francofolies
ces barrettes mais risquent en plus de
ça de celui publié à travers les villes
de france et de faire en sorte qu'ils en
bavent arrivera où les exclus ceux que
cette société en jambes et ne seront
plus dans les villes a lieu on voit
revivre
le maire de la rochelle est critiquée
par le premier ministre de l'époque
alain juppé mais aussi dans son propre
camp au sein du parti socialiste
malgré ces critiques d'autres villes
socialistes et même communiste signait
aussi s'est arrêté comme tarbes ou pau
pour les associations le combat se joue
sur le terrain judiciaire savoir si ces
arrêtés sont légaux ou non et la
décision tombe pendant l'été 95 si on en
croit une circulaire du ministère de
l'intérieur les arrêtés d'interdiction
pris par certains maires seraient légaux
mais dans certaines conditions des
conditions qui sont toujours les mêmes
aujourd'hui les arrêtés anti mendicité
ne peuvent être pris que pour une
période donnée et des lieux précis les
mendiants risque est alors une amende de
38 euros
[Musique]